citizens of the reject Nation it is John
it is Roxy stryer and together we are
Ron joxie yes nailed it we were debating
beforehand what our combined name should
be if you like Ron jaxi comment below
but we are here today to continue our
blade Journey with easily the most
beloved blade film all of you have told
us it's your favorite and it's the best
it's Blade Trinity and we could not be
more excited to send this series off
with a bang Roxy star how you feeling
I'm feeling nervous because we loved
blade one we love blade 2. I saw some
people in the comments saying Blade 3
actually is underrated okay so I'ma hold
on to that hope absolutely I am too and
you what you guys should do is hold on
to that like button hold on to that
subscribe and notification Bell let us
know you're enjoying these and what else
you might want to see next make sure to
follow Roxy in the world girls while
you're clicking all those buttons and
last but not least as always if you want
to enjoy the full experience of Blade
Trinity with us everything that doesn't
make these reaction highlights come on
over to patreon.com slash the real
rejects we got tons of awesome content
over there sync up with your own copy it
is a blast and without further Ado are
you ready for blade
born ready to cut deep blade
killing it roll the bumper
in the movies Dracula wears a cape and
some old English guy always manages to
save the day at the last minute with
crosses and holy water that's definitely
Ryan Reynolds yeah what did you know
Ryan Reynolds voice was about to pop up
not at all but you can recognize it a
mile away even when he's chill Deadpool
introducing blade dude maybe Wesley will
show up and play in uh Deadpool three
that'd be dope
oh
take that song yeah totally F you son
how dare you beam
structurally sound absolutely we should
just go right down in there it's
cuneiform it's about 4 000 years old so
why here because this is the cradle of
civilization whoa Parker Posey there's
something beneath us
you find a watch instead of body
[Music]
totally fair reaction not overreacting
whoa
okay the strobe is intense
they're about to blow this rat up now
the rat's gonna Defuse The Bomb
oh
it's like the sound that I can make yeah
to be a Foley artist you're welcome
editors
cool as ever
wow how do you do that backward because
his instincts are so sharp
nice
whip knife this
what is Trinity that is that a religious
term like holy trinity
and goes there but it's any you know
Trio triumvirate
Etc but in this I mean I don't know
we'll find out
[Music]
she's a really fast editing in this
movie what did we determine he's
shooting them with silver bullets is
that what's happening yeah I guess so
we'll get a montage of him filling
shells with silver buckshot
nice the UV headlights
every time I see a car get destroyed in
a movie my heart hurts a little bit oh
I could drive that you could just give
it to me cars for kids
1877 cars for Roxy Strayer
so badass every time his face is so
still mistaken with silver why don't you
ask why aren't you smarter you're not a
vampire dumb [__] see a wolf oh set your
sorry ass up one of those fake fangs
there's a human
no
just a human damn familiars why aren't
you smarter you dumb [__]
a cabin tonight
he's human getting Reckless blade
killing vampires clean the ash don't
leave in the heavens by except the ash
what's this new delivery system for your
syrup it's an effervescent inhaler just
bite down on the mouth guard delivery is
automatic some friends of mine made it
they're also good with Exposition now
apparently
array okay we've got a lead let's go to
playing Wilson time to take these
Cowboys down Cowboys let's go let's do a
buddy cop movie what's he been doing
God is feeling been through five of them
so far he allowed us to take him in I'm
gonna go in
yeah you are
oh
yeah black lights hats now do you know
the blade comics like is Danica Talos or
whatever her name was somebody to know
couldn't tell you comment below people
she's actually a scroll she's related to
Telos the scroll
whoa
whoa oh
that's like Sauron and a baby with a
Reaper yes
you shouldn't have worked with me what
oh no way Dominic Purcell
Prison Break let's go do this the
world's changed since your time the
humans have a new Hunter
and you'd like me to kill him wouldn't
you yeah it'd be nice I've interviewed
him several times really yeah he's
awesome oh shouts out he watches this
channel certainly he doesn't remember
any of his roles ever nothing it's good
every roll is a fresh slate yes
now it's not just vampires we've got to
worry about we're going to have to take
on the rest of the world too now take on
your Public Image I've been doing this
since before you were born blade you're
like a son to me I'm sorry I got old on
you I see you alone surrounded by
enemies we can't win this war alone yeah
but who can you trust us that's true we
would be good vampire Hunters well it
looks like we got ourselves a combo meal
so let's serenade them with drums
they're gonna try to eat the baby yeah
man gotta get that fresh blood chicky
yeah don't you turn around when you were
getting cat called
Barrel on through
I want a mask like that I feel like more
people should do blade costumes for
Halloween not just play the character
but all the characters it's just every
yeah get like a group of 20 people and
dress all as The prominent figures yeah
walk around with this loaf of bread
you'll be a hit at the party aprily
[Music]
of course it's the X Games vampires
do you think this is foreshadowing
because he looks like Justin Timberlake
what garlic yes
[Music]
I wonder if there's a shortage of just
jars of powdered garlic in the city yeah
staked in the nuts
but what is she she's Jessica freaking
bill that's what she is she's Buffy bro
she kind of looks like Faith just
because he's got Eliza Dushku thing
Eliza Dushku in the house again
[Music]
ah
Wowie
[Music]
what is that it's a lightsaber dude you
never saw one of course might be pretty
much this hurts chica yeah
it did hurt
what is it what you're worried about oh
no people have done followed us
let's go let's go let's go no sometimes
the way this is edited makes you feel
like very panicky yeah it's very kinetic
yeah
like different angle angle angle angle
yeah lots and lots of coverage I like
that I'm using layman terms and then
you're making it elevated and nice I'm
here to translate for the cine files
okay
[Music]
ah
no I can't do that to my boy
go take that little [__]
oh I think I kill my man again not this
early move a finger in your debt I was
about this one he's got something in his
hand get up blade
get every angle
jump don't you
don't shoot I want them alive
[Music]
no I don't like a defeated blade yeah
you look so sad I know acting that's
right blade took a class special agents
Ray Cumberland Wilson Hale FBI we've
been tracking you a long time Whistler
dead no no he's not right I don't know
I hope not so how many people have you
killed blade 30 40 50 60 70 80 90.
1182. wow my name is Dr Vance I've been
charged with giving you a psychiatric
evaluation would you mind giving us just
a couple of minutes alone he looks like
a superhero and a red shirt yeah that
should be his new outfit with a big old
B on the chest like to look like a
superhero and a t-shirt can you tell me
what day it is
how about the president
do you know who's in the white house
right now
what year is this 2004 vampires what can
you tell me about that they exist are
you one of them when you drink blood do
you feel yourself becoming sexually
aroused but
and I'm wondering what your relationship
was like with your mother yeah good
question let's go Freud
was it to be very close
oh we know what happened he's psychotic
Hospital something to keep you compliant
and the usual dose for this sort of
thing is two 300 milligrams but I think
with a kick it up to a couple thousand
you don't have a problem with needles do
you again how many neck injections
happen in real life
I mean you've had a lot of help today
it's the end game played
we're at the end game now
relax
damn it they're all corrupt was that the
same guy's tattoo we just saw or the
other ones no it's the other guy too
they were in coats both the cops and the
psych well like the chief and the psych
guy at least yeah the superior officer
but one of the cops isn't I think the
two cops we saw are not like the two
actually brought him in the one guy
above them is yeah
this is
go the guy with the pony I keep I think
I can't place how I know him but I do
yeah it looks familiar you're all alone
blade No One's Gonna help you now why
would they take him out of his
what are you an idiot oh
wow
eating ladies
[Music]
Hannibal King I did not realize this was
coming
wow
yeah stretch it out totally
[Music]
go okay
so were those maybe silver restraints or
whatever or how did he get his powers
back just now it was that respiratory oh
that thing oh yeah yeah that's what he's
biting on I was like what that the
friend made you know friends
[Music]
like they got a second to do a badass
slow walk now we get a hallway fight
[Music]
Reynolds look very or 2000s with that
spiky hair yeah
and that beard
[Music]
what daughter Whistler is that what you
got from that that's yeah
[Music]
got like a wrestler or something I
thought he was asking which way Whistler
was
I can't shoot around corners I can
[Music]
sick
yes ricocheted Arrow
[Music]
first
hahaha
[Music]
yes
do you think senior whistler's dead uh
uh 50 50. oh my God that's not a good
answer I think he's been dead once so he
could come back but I feel like we
didn't see him die yeah exactly oh
all right
I had to read the evidence Locker for my
gear who the hell are you people my name
is Handel King and this little Hellion
right here is Afghan whistler's daughter
Exposition can't believe that I I needed
that sure
you didn't it was a weak moment of mine
it's all good we all have weaknesses
that's why an exec had them put that in
the movie this is Hedges some field
inhaler of yours that's Natasha Leone I
didn't see it the runt you saw earlier
that was Summerfield's daughter Zoe damn
we call ourselves the night stalkers so
I was like rejects from a Saturday
morning cartoon real rejects
your kids you're not ready to roll with
this
look at the way you dressed but that's
supposed to be tactical they broke you
out you think this is a joke you think
this is a [__] sitcom
that's just rude I'm pretty sure we
saved your ass back there
I'm impressed
like it or not we are all you got the
hell makes you think you know about
hunting vampires is for starters I used
to be one wowie you know the kind of
woman that just screams trouble is here
and every morning Bell in your brain
starts going off but you still managed
to ask for her number but that's all I
ever hook up with
she blew them all away in the [__] storm
sweepstakes her name is Danica Talos and
unlike typical vampires her fangs are
located nervous
I've seen that movie too first movie me
and Greg watched on Netflix way back in
the day we need to pull our resources
blade he's come back take a look at this
this is really Dracula Dracula is only
one of the names he's gone by the
Babylonians worshiped him as Dagon and
now they call him Drake
now they call him champagne poppy he was
the first of his kind
the patriarch
of hominis nocturna
scientific name they found him in Iraq
about six months ago and he was pissed
this is a weird facial hair look for
Ryan Reynolds yeah it's so like sculpted
llama deep you yeah I gotta get more of
those shirts what's with the Vampire and
cross thing you mean them being like
warded off by crossover he's wearing a
cross and vampires and Crosses I feel
like yeah I mean this in this universe I
don't think it does anything so it's
like you know it's a good way to kind of
give some attitude but also blend in you
know you sell vampire merchandise yeah
look around we might have a few things
what
you want to kiss me pretty boy is that
you do that
so I'm like whoa weird slightly
homophobic comments in this movie yeah
see nowadays that guy would just be
serious he'd just be like you want a
kiss like I'll do it yeah you know and
then otherwise the other one like my old
really solid we need a new tactic like
what a biological weapon yeah yes oh my
God she's a baby yeah for the last year
I've been working with synthesized DNA
in order to create an artificial virus
targeted specifically of vampires so
what's been holding you back we need
Dracula's blood of course you do UV Arc
the two points are connected by a
powerful UV laser
yes yup have you ever been laid many
times with ladies
I can't take Ryan Reynolds seriously
sometimes he's so what are you talking
about he's so believable he's amazing
but he's hysterical
oh
whoa very stylized yep split screen
swipe split screen it's like a comic
book please
I swear
is that Evan Moss or no hello this is Dr
Vance you page me it's for you yeah go
ahead hello
you know at some point you might want to
consider sitting down with somebody kick
back get in touch with your inner child
that sort of thing you might want to
consider blinking once in a while
how does he know he's not blinking I
know he's got the shades like
and who needs to Blink when you got the
shades like why have I never seen
anybody dressed as Jessica Beale in
Blade three for Halloween you know what
yours should be the first
[Music]
I'm sorry but you can't see Dr Vance
right now
no all right Vance what the hell do you
know
oh Jesus it's him Abby it's Drake
shift in
I can't get over his name is Drake I
know I had a feeling about you just
shoot him go ahead blade show me what
you made
oh
nice if you could shape-shift into
somebody for a day who would it be ooh
um see I was shapeshifter the Wesley
Snipes Man
spent my day being the coolest dude
alive
foreign
[Music]
I do appreciate the sheer amount of
Destruction in this Chase yeah so many
casualties it's just Kool-Aid Manning
through this building
[Music]
oh
interesting stairwell white looking up
red looking down do you think babies
have sweeter blood definitely it's not
been tainted by life
careful day Walker why'd you kill fans
it all lived his purpose
he died a good death I wouldn't know
anything about that you will
do you think they could ever grasp what
it means to be immortal you're not
immortal I must have heard hundreds of
you rodents make the same claim
each one of them has tasted the end of
my sword but I think it is more likely
the next time we meet
you far before mine
I was fighting words
what a dad it's gonna sting a little
really
[Music]
oh geez the bubbling though that did
look painful we're successful say we
wipe out all the vampires want that huh
and somehow I don't
picture you teaching karate at the local
y oh dude I would love that karate at
the local y
he hates me doesn't he
don't believe whistler's dead
why do you do that sad card yes
she got a line
because there's something bad
inside of me
why can't you just be nice
their question because the world isn't
nice Fair answer I wish he was just like
I never thought of that before
genetic sequencing enzymes you want a
party favor
yeah
silver hollow points done
do you want a party favor
yeah that that UV you know bow thing
that's half as hard as the sun done
what are you doing here
talk
oh
spill it you know what we're doing
what's inside
whoa no what's behind door number one I
can't tell you they'll kill me kill you
brother I'll kill you
[Laughter]
I do like the blades a little more loose
in this movie yeah
like of everyone getting cool guy
dialogue his is my favorite whoa
got Jim Morrison
whoa
oh this is crazy it's like daybreakers
again
why kill your prey when you can keep
them alive under optimal conditions a
donor can generate anywhere from 50 to
100 pints of blood
productive oh
at any given time there's what two three
million homeless wandering around
America
oh
are they aware do they feel anything
they're in a chemical induced coma
a brain dead they are experiencing
nothingness Oblivion they're going to
win can't you see that just come back
there's nothing stopping them now that's
me yeah
absolutely there's you you've got 20
seconds
20.
[Laughter]
cool I loved that moment
foreign
[Music]
we'll see they must have a contingency
or we won't see
maybe it's just sad
oh she is blind okay
[Music]
there you go Patton whoa I knew it I
wouldn't let it go and I knew it but is
he I don't know about that changed very
possibly he's the villain now or did he
shape-shift into him that's what's going
on hello
dude
you're dead
[Music]
started from the bottom now we're here
guys
do not kill Natasha Leone
no
no we'd only just met
[Music]
no
don't worry she'll restart the day over
again sweet birthday baby groundhog say
it's a Russian doll reference Roxanne oh
[Music]
his fingers stretching that was gnarly
yeah those Nosferatu fingers
nowadays shouting King just you know is
just like a joke Zoe
no
don't fall for it I don't know of course
he's calling her
that's what happened to me at the
beginning
could that be you
ask your doctor for immortality is right
for you
AstraZeneca
oh no
oh poor thing where's the daughter this
is very the joker-esque sure
trying to torture him
use it
what like the pain or yeah channel that
rage channel to hurt
yes
scream it out
oh
dog's a vampire
I think that was true
that was the thing yeah
importing the vampire genius other
species experimenting you made a god
vampire Pomeranian Vamp Pomeranian
vampiranian Vamp precious enemy well
that depends who you ask because clearly
this dog has a bigger dick than you
and when the [__] did you see my face
that is the best response to that
it looks like he could be Wolverine
right now yeah look at that Marvel bod
right there I know
what would hurt you more than anything
oh ow you don't want to go back to being
one of us
do you because we could really use a
go-getter Like You on the team on the
team that's right I'm going to watch
when you become a vampire do you just
get a tattoo
there must be somebody there somebody
from the family is like yeah we gotta
Mark you up
bring the little girl in here
for human beat on jeez
[Music]
is that 240 frames per second it says
FPS
Force per shot I don't know hey that's
actually maybe not bad that's that might
be what it is
much colder I'll be your driver this
evening okay intense what if this was
entirely scored by Drake that would be
that would be something else if you're
watching this I'm already dead
oh my I want you to promise me that
you'll take care of her okay
I've been reading her the Oz books every
night we just started reading the
Emerald City of Oz
you know the one with the known King
oh yes King as a precaution I
transmitted the genetic sequence to
colder in case our main stock was
destroyed you're gonna need to infuse it
with Drake's blood every vampire in the
immediate vicinity should die almost
instantly
good you need to know there's a chance
of ours could destroy you too I'm not
sure if your immune system will be able
to tolerate it
I'm sorry
we just didn't have enough time to
properly test it
when did you make this video like
an hour ago
before she went to go find I guess it's
gonna be shot from one of the four
battle rifles
you must be sure that the shot counts
Chris hired all is
I don't know who that is
he's a great character actor too he pops
up in all sorts of stuff he looks
familiar but I don't know the name
do you want to die yes I'm Not Afraid
yes
yes you will love her
spit on him what if you could remain a
child forever
wouldn't you like that that would suck
interesting what age would you want to
be stuck at forever
good one
eight I don't know time of Innocence
before all this mess no drugs I'm like 8
or 22. pick one
[Music]
yeah suit up
Boomerang knife let's take it back to
the concrete streets
synchronize bike riding look at that
Jessica bieloki is a great action star
I'm here for ya
sniffy little tracking now it's
surgically implanted in your body you
see when one of us goes missing the
others they just dial up the satellite
which is in space
oh
instant Cavalry after you know a few
hours did you see that tickle that
you're feeling in the back of your
throat right now oh that's atomized
colloidal silver oh it's being pumped
through the building's air conditioning
system you juggling Thunder
wowie
whoa Dragon fat lady should be singing
right about now Drake's doing a collab
do you have a cell phone
foreign
yo ripped she's auditioning for Tomb
Raider right now yeah and the part's
hers
sure dude she worked out for this look
at his arms hell yeah
that's right you should have been
flexing this whole time take us to the
gun show Roxanne
oh geez
nice I wanna boot knife
it's okay stunt team guy you got your
featured moments
we've been waiting it's the sickest you
okay
oh nice
me
oh yeah now it's me sideways now it's
Resident Evil
oh he's a cute little guy aren't you
sideways what a shock this is a weird
term also yes
aren't you usually sideways
often often times I guess not always but
often
they framed him through that dog's legs
me standing up like that would be the
Rarity yeah yeah or upside down upside
down difficult
wow
nicely done Chris Redfield sorry
Resident Evil jokes okay
awesome
seen my dog
have you tried the lobby
oh
ready to die
I was born ready mother yeah
sometimes his head went back with no
punch yeah
where's Jessica Biel with the kid she'll
step in and like save him at a crucial
moment
people ever get into fights like this in
real life I feel like a lot of real life
fist fights very short yeah and not very
stylish
come on man Vanquish the six God
oh King
it's killing me where he's from
yeah he looks so familiar oh
twofer
[Music]
saw a movie now whoa
this is cool death should have done that
earlier yeah
let's wake you up
[Music]
kind of a weird moment but I'm into it
wow
oh no
thank you
oh
yeah if you're reading this it's too
late
[Music]
take him out take him out take him out
God's plan
he caught it
grab it please
oh
yeah yeah damn
little tiny little platelets floating up
into the sky that's wild looking yeah
but is it gonna kill blade yep
definitely that's why the franchise
ended after this terrific final send-off
foreign
if you're breathing this it's too late
that would have been a better Drake joke
give it up King she said give it up King
go off go off King
no no Parker Posey I don't need to
survive the future of our race rests
with you uh-huh sinner
or later
thirst
what a line
bring the big sigh of relief blade
what if the Vampire part of him died but
the human part lives that'd be an
interesting turn of events and then
blade finally gets to retire and raise
little Zoe
blade four yeah blade and Zoe yeah and
then it'll be like Batman Beyond where
it's like old man blade and then Zoe's
out hunting vampires some logan-ish yeah
you idiot yeah what good are you FBI
couldn't even track down a hive of Vamps
Federal Bureau of idiots yep
the tickets
certain jacket off or was that Drake and
Drake's final gift let's just say the
FBI got their body
got their mixtape just wasn't the one
they were banking on oh that's why he
had no shirts that's why he had no shirt
it was all there
incredible
that was cool You Drake
thank you six God blade was still out
there somewhere his life was a war
and everybody knows the war never ends
nice shot
[Music]
okay
written and directed by David S goyer
okay damn man I wonder what happened to
them I don't know nice cool credit
medley oh the Rizza did coded the music
that's neat that's kind of cool felt
like a very hip score
it's even hipper when you say it I know
especially in that white guy voice
I appreciate they made these credits a
music video so is the Trinity blade
Jessica Biel and Ryan Reynolds that's
right the definitive Trinity or is it
the Pomeranian yeah the two dogs it was
those three dogs yeah totally and they
get this like Christopher Guest starter
pack on loan Triple H he was a wrestler
there you go obviously Triple H
idiot idiot
I can't believe that yeah I figured it
had to be yeah like I was like no no
this guy oh my God
take away my [__] card for anything
ever
yeah you failed this way let the records
show how badly you have that wasn't down
the road
you're off my team Roxy I [__] with
Triple H sure how could you not
recognize him in this start making
performance he looks pretty much the
same now too with his hair back like
that wow yeah [__] Triple H that's
crazy that I didn't pick up on that that
is King nuts it's okay we just watched
The Watcher boy for the first time and
The Big Show is in that and uh I know I
know this guy I know I know him oh my
God
you guys at home must have been
screaming at me every time I was like
um I know him that's yeah those angry
comments man you're gonna be you'll
never forget Triple H's face holy [__]
after this damn man I just did Triple H
did Roxanne I hope you are prepared to
do a bad apology I do feel like I did
that I didn't I could have made a lot
more Drake references anytime I'm
feeling like a failure yeah totally 100
every time we've talked about like uh in
life not just me and you but people
right you talk about Cena you talk about
the rock you talk about Batista
um Sasha Banks like anybody because of
Becky Lynch
Ronda Rousey is in a movie or two
totally
um and Triple H I feel like many times
people have said yeah played three and I
just never like put the pieces together
Kane was in see no evil
nor did I but he's in it he's a couple
of those movies damn I'm so so bummed
with myself right now Hulk Hogan also
did a bunch of movies yeah Stone Cold
Steve Austin yeah well what did you
think of the film what did you think of
Blade Trinity I thought it was solid
really okay I thought I think it wasn't
it was my least favorite of the three
um and there was moments that are not
solid but overall I think because I had
such low expectations going in I totally
think it's serviceable yeah it's fun
like it's it's cheesy and it doesn't
have nearly the flow and the mood that
the first two do but I'm not gonna
pretend like I didn't just have fun
right now I mean right I'll put on the
first two way sooner than I'll re-watch
this it's not egregious though it's not
like you're watching it and you hate
watching it and you're like oh this is
sucks it's like it definitely it's it's
okay yeah it definitely feels like
somebody's like I feel bad for David go
here saying this but it felt like some
producer's nephew wrote the script
because just like the dialogue is is
just so much the dialogue's tough is
just like everyone's talking like a cool
guy and swearing and interesting and
creative ways that I feel like are very
much aimed at like a high school
audience yeah and it was some of the
editing choices were challenging too
it's like very jarring at times but I
still love blade as a character oh yeah
I'll watch them all day and I really
like Jessica Biel and this and I like I
think it was fun to have her and Ryan
Reynolds and kind of play off each other
like there's parts that are silly work
for me because it was enjoyable uh and I
still think like the costume design sick
you know there's stuff there are
elements that I'm like yeah that really
works yeah like it's always a joy to
watch Wesley Snipes we got a little bit
with the word it just says a word
oh
god post credits
[Music]
blade will return is Blade the
originator of the post-credit scene
very first post-credits scene we should
go back and film it 2004. so this is a
113 minutes it definitely felt longer
than that to me this felt like a two and
a half hour movie it did drag at times
um horror drama gritty intense yeah I
don't know about the horror part I would
put cheesy yeah into the like this one
has the most
defined element of Camp I feel like this
honestly like though this is nearly a
two-hour movie and though it does in
some ways feel longer than that uh it
also felt like I was watching like an
episode of a blade TV show and I know
there is a blade TV show people have
mentioned but uh you know anime is live
action it was like a one one season show
different guy
um I don't know anything about that but
but watching this I was like this does
feel like this got adapted for TV and
now I'm watching like a pilot that
somehow they were allowed to do a lot of
wearing throughout but like even a lot
of the violence and and the gore gags
and stuff were like a lot less like this
felt like a PG-13 movie with an R-rated
dialogue pass well there was a lot I
mean I I swear every other word but this
movie really swore every other word this
movie reminded me of your friend in high
school who just like wants to say the
most outlandish swear word salad
combinations just because they want to
come off as like cool as possible like
that's the thing it's like
the Ryan Reynolds character feels like
you know every teenage guy's fantasy
like when you're 13 and you're drawing
like anime characters and you're like
yeah this is my cool guy you know you
literally asked at one point cool beard
and he's got the spiky hair and and you
know he's always got an attitude and a
quip in the chamber you know yeah you
said did Ryan Reynolds write his own
dialogue and I was like oh no that means
that John cannot be enjoying it no I was
enjoying it but it was that thing where
like looking back over so many years
this is before Ryan Reynolds was like
the brand that he is now and yet even
back then it feels like he's doing his
Ryan Reynolds thing right like you know
it's
it's toned down like three to five
percent from where it is now but like
yeah I mean he's pretty much just doing
his attitude and his you know thing that
he brings to a movie so like I I think I
expected
you know it's like when you see you know
somebody with a really high profile
earlier on in their career you know you
see them before the Persona is developed
or is here I was like oh this feels
pretty much like seeing him in X-Men
Origins or Deadpool or any number of
other things did you watch two guys a
girl on a pizza place no what is that oh
okay two guys a girl on a pizza place is
a TV show that Ryan Reynolds starred in
I'm gonna say in the late 90s that I was
obsessed with
um and he was this was two guys a girl
in a pizza place to me just like with a
different beard I mean sure I'm telling
you two guys a girl in a pizza place 98
1998. oh wow um vintage Reynolds yeah it
was it's the first time I ever saw him
and I grew up on Ryan Reynolds and then
later on I think that's one of the first
things that he ever did but it kind of
reminded me he was very goofy in that
and he was very goofy in this well yeah
I I remember like yeah this is the
earliest probably action role now I've
seen for him because I'm yeah like back
in the day I was used to the idea of him
as like Van Wilder or various other
comedic roles yeah at raunchy comedies
yeah yeah I definitely feel you I mean I
think that he is just so great I watched
this year welcome to wrexham which is he
bought the soccer team and it was the
doc about him buying the soccer team in
Rob mceleney mclarney however he say it
from Ollie sunny it's always sunny yeah
Mac yes
um and I think that he is I think Ryan
Reynolds is truly like unbelievably
dynamic as a human and as a performer
but it was a little jarring in this
movie The juxtaposition of him and blade
like it just felt like they were in two
different
even Jessica Biel like Jessica Biel and
blade were in one movie yeah and Natasha
Leon was in one movie yeah and then Ryan
Reynolds and sometimes that's life you
know sometimes characters in life is
like what room do you think you're in so
it's not like it never would happen but
it was very like this is the Ryan
Reynolds show but um yeah totally like
they it feels like they let him walk
around and do improv and stuff like that
and I and I don't know what the vibe
would have been if that was like his
thing or if the director if David goyer
was just like yes go this is gold let's
get it yeah um I mean yeah and that
gives it a certain additional I guess
like comic bookiness because again all
the dialogue is kind of like that but
this one like you know I I appreciate
across all these movies that you have
you know blade is this sort of singular
figure he's got Whistler to some extent
and the twistler in this yeah I did too
like I was sad that he left so early and
I get that they got a set up uh uh
what's her name Ally or whatever Abby
Abby the daughter yeah but at the same
time I was sad that he had to completely
depart in order for that to happen and
and I think that they could have done a
lot more with the emotionality of that I
mean not that again this is trying to be
a drama and this movie I think out of
all of them is the least concerned with
those kinds of Storytelling flourishes
but I would have liked some kind of
mourning or just some kind of more
emotional send-off for Whistler or I
don't know like
yeah we don't really know because yeah
it's like it looked like he died but we
didn't see it so nowadays especially
that usually means nobody's dead and for
his daughter it's like yeah you have
that like
shower scene you have a couple moments
but like she just lost her father from
whom she probably had like an odd
relationship given you know his life of
vampire fighting and and their whole
traumatic experience from the backstory
and everything so like it would have
been I feel like nice to commemorate
that somehow
uh but yeah like these movies all have
like a fun Dynamic of like it's blade
and Whistler and then you've got like a
colorful cast of like additional
semi-allies he's got to work with and
that creates like a fun friction dynamic
between them and then you know whoever
the new super Vamp monster is like it
has all the ingredients of a blade movie
uh and it's certainly like clipped along
but it's not as stylish like there's a
lot of stuff that's like hyper edited
and just like tons of cover like there
are a couple fights I thought that
nicely
still accentuated or attempted to
accentuate you know Wesley snipes's
motion especially you know his prowess
is a martial artist but there's a lot of
stuff in here that uh feels a little bit
like a like an editing salad you know
and that also kind of reminded me of a
TV show because you have way less time
to shoot all that stuff so oftentimes
you'll just have a lot of Wick pans and
a lot of Quick Cuts
um which you know it wasn't full on that
here but it certainly was like the the
least uh Punchy in terms of the action
not that I didn't like some of like his
uh his retractable like um the knife on
the lead I thought was kind of a neat
thing he got to use the boomerang knife
once they have all these crazy ass
gadgets but even that was like all right
we got our crazy gadgets and here's our
like Montage of like showing off the
gadgets and stuff this this just felt
like uh like a bunch of modular elements
being plugged in rather than a
story that went from beginning to end
you're colder on this than I am it was
fun but it has like way more like I can
easily see how this is a drop off would
you say this is a c for you
yeah maybe like a c I might put a Plus
on it for enjoyability because again I
was never annoyed I was never bored I
was never upset by anything I was just
like after the first two it was average
true yeah it was it was pretty I feel
like mid would be like kind of a mean
thing to say about it but yeah it was
kind of average it was it was
it was fun enough but after the first
two you know clearly we've seen how it
can be way better and not feel uh quite
so I don't know it just felt like it was
like just chop chop moving along and
they have so many interesting characters
and I was like oh cool Parker Posey
holding it down for part threes of
horror franchises here and like I liked
why what what part three did Parker
Posey do scream three oh pretty uh
famous like Parker Posey turn from uh
she wants to come back to scream and uh
yeah yeah yeah I'm here for it but it's
like you've got them and they're kind of
characters but then you've got Drake and
Drake is kind of you know he is the big
bad but I feel like both of them kind of
get shuffled around and slightly
diminished by just like the overall
structure of the movie is Drake the best
you ever had
yourself of course always yes I'm
waiting for that for two hours oh it's
okay it's honestly never mind it's okay
try it I'm like I'm I'm running out the
road I don't have the biggest Drake
lexicons running through all my okay
really good really it actually was
interesting that they didn't name him
Drake though and that they did have a
character King like things that at the
time they never know would be
distracting but in 2023 it's
unbelievably distracting to have one
character named Drake and one character
named King yeah it just was like yeah
every time the king thing you and I had
to hold back laughter and it's like that
they never could have predicted that
that would turn into what it did but
it's like get up King and I'm like yeah
[Music]
like that worked out I think like I
think that appreciated and valuable as
opposed to Drake yeah where it's like
yeah Drake you're just thinking about
Drake and I liked I mean I liked that
lore element of like ah you know Dracula
he's taking many forms and they do that
thing of like oh you know some of the
lore he doesn't turn into mist but he
could shape-shift and he's been called
many things and now it's been sanded
down by time to where he's called Drake
now and he's got this crazy form and
like I liked all that stuff it's like
this is a movie where I I I had fun
but I can easily see how you could take
everything that they had at their
disposal and make a much better version
yes I hear you because do you had all
the the daybreakers thing where you have
all the people in the blood bags the
like the homeless folks that they are
harvesting and I was like that's an
interesting idea we should explore oh no
that's just kind of like a neat set
piece and then we leave there and we
don't really think about it again and
even like the science stuff was like as
neat I liked having it uh you know this
whole like we've developed a new you
know poison and if we can just get you
know Dracula's blood we can wipe them
all out or at least all of them near
here
um you know things like that are cool
it's just like nothing ever really like
immerses you far enough to you feel or
that I felt like the true weight or the
stakes like everything kind of breezed
by and it felt much lighter and much
more like a uh like a just a you know a
chapter it felt like a episode of like
episodic TV where like everything's
gonna reset next week whereas the first
two feel like they flow from one to the
other I definitely feel that even with
the post-credits scene where it's like
yeah more to come for you does it go one
two three
probably I too I liked a lot like I
think yeah probably one just because it
has a bit more of the breathing space
and more of the
um I don't know yeah you never forget
your first it's got all those iconic
moments it's got a nice sort of breath
to the tone while also having all the
action
um the second one though I still think
is really imaginative and fun and
action-packed but yeah I guess for that
little extra ounce of like tone and
story oomph I would put one at the top
but some days I might put two at the top
but you know it's like one two
and then you know leave a space and then
three
I'm like three I like significantly less
but it's still fun like if I I wouldn't
go out of my way not to buy the three
pack if that was the choice yeah yeah
you know because yeah I really liked
having Jessica Beale and I thought she
it's weird it's like it's fun having
both her and Ryan Reynolds Ryan Reynolds
is fun to watch for the you know the
like Cinema anthropology of it yeah he
is
um but you know he's in his own movie
he's doing his own thing he's you know
the kind of
Center Point from where all this high
school kid dialogue is coming from and
everybody too the king thing and the
Drake thing like it's another one of
those where like everyone's got a cool
name and everyone calls everyone by name
all the time and I'm like it's cool when
people call blade blade all the time but
when you're when everyone's like hey
King what's going on King you think you
you think you're better than us kingsler
Whistler yeah I'm like okay clearly you
think these are very cool names and this
this movie just feels like a guy trying
to be super cool and he's only happy Joe
he's got the cool jacket but clearly you
can tell he's trying way too hard to be
cool just the whole movie not Ryan
Reynolds specifically but like I'm
devastated about the Triple H lack of
knowledge that I just displayed
put some respect on Triple H's name bro
and I mean stuff like that like I love
that they included him and I and I like
that he at least gets to be a prominent
Hench character but I feel like even in
a previous blade movie it's like I think
back to having Donald Logan the first
one he's just a Hench but he's like
prominent you don't really ever forget
about him he's got a good amount of
personality and I liked what Triple H
did here but I was like man you know in
a slightly different movie he might have
had even more to do or or Parker Posey
like Parker Posey I really liked I
thought she was gonna be the I thought
she was going to be the big bad at the
beginning and then she just kind of gets
lost so I'm like yeah there's a big
chunk without her where I was like huh
yeah I thought that it was Dominic
Purcell like I thought it was Parker
Posey big bad then Dominic but then it
totally yeah once he's Dracula you're
like oh yeah yeah totally um but yeah
it's like I liked her presence and I
liked her look and Vibe and and and I
think there is something to the
campiness that they went for with this
movie that could have worked in a more
like
uh in in a way where I'm not asterisking
so hard it's like again I enjoyed it but
whereas like I feel like there's a
version where I'm like I love the
cheesiness because you know not in spite
of I'm not trying to shoehorn this into
every review we do although I am but do
you know I feel like this movie needed
any little romance I Need A Little
Romance it could have used I'm not I'm
not effing around guys I get whereas
blade one and Blade Two didn't have as
much room for it don't you feel like
this movie had room for it either
between
um Ryan Reynolds and and uh Jessica Biel
or blade and Jessica Biel or Natasha
Leone and Jessica
I'll take that one any version of that
or even Parker Posey and Dominic Purcell
like there's just there was room for
there was room for sexy Dad yeah don't
tell me you couldn't have made out in
this movie not at all Yeah well yeah
you're gonna give me three you're gonna
give me a vampire Trilogy with no
[__] at all
I think that's egregious it is a little
bit and I know and I read all your
comments and I love you guys and you're
just like why is Roxy lover of Love
shippers ships cause I am
cause I am yeah and it's a Hallmark of
the genre I'll give it to you I mean
blood the next sexiness make out take
your shirts off I mean I would even get
some shirtless stuff we got a lot of
shirtless stuff jeez I mean we got
shirtless Dominic Purcell which I feel
like he only got bigger after this oh he
only got more jacked but uh Ryan
Reynolds man that was like oh I didn't
expect you to be so buff in this movie
and then we got a shirtless Blaze
shirtless blade absolutely I mean you
know the coolest guy ever that's the
thing it's like I I would have even
settled for one of those like the the
first movie and the second movie with
blade kind of have more so the second
even have this thing where yeah you have
this sort of main supporting female lead
and you're like oh is there is there
something there maybe a little bit and
and it doesn't ever really come to
fruition or anything but that makes
sense given what the stories are I could
have done something like that because
like I would be a little conflicted if
it's like okay Blade's gonna get with
whistler's daughter but uh I hear you I
hear you there could be some kind of
latent magnetism though and that's a
neat little Nuance I think the previous
two have that's kind of unique whereas
yeah here there's not really any of that
or yeah you could have Parker Posey like
trying to live up to Dracula or trying
to please him trying to you know be his
you know right hand and and you know and
Sharon you know Eternal decadent love
and blood and all that stuff yeah like
just a lot of opportunities thank you
thank you sure absolutely
um and yeah stamps like to Bone they do
they're all about it and it's a lust
thing sure we didn't even see the dogs
boning you don't think Vamp dogs are
gonna be humping each other I'm not
saying I want to see that I'm just
saying there's so much editing on this
review
it's okay it's okay it's okay just uh
just just less uh direct terminology
bone
fairer I guess it's all contact
YouTube's getting smarter about context
what can I call it
passionate love me yeah oh it feels
worse yeah nothing gets people drippy
moist like some passionate love making
but like this is it's also one of those
that you have so many great elements and
you have a great Ensemble a lot of
character actors and yeah like you get a
patent Oswald he he was he was making it
he was in it he had but he had uh at
least you know made love made sweet love
a couple times established it was
represented to women somewhere yes he
specified which got you know no need to
be insecure man we all go through phases
yeah there were a couple moments where I
was just like this does feel very 90s
not 2000s the way that they're treating
like yeah same sex whatever it is sure
yeah everybody's got to go out of their
way to be like I'm super straight cool
very straight cool and straight yeah
yeah whereas now yeah the fun is is kind
of riding the line to a degree but but
yeah it's like I really liked Jessica
Beals presence you know like I don't
think it's a kind of movie that gives
her like a real opportunity to to shine
with the material but I really like your
presence I like that she clearly like
put in the work I believed her most of
the time when she was fighting yeah like
she her like at least her arms you see
her arms and like it looks like she
really worked out like she got kind of
built for this and I love I love when
people especially actresses like to
throw down for that because I think
there's often that pressure to be like
still be dainty but also Kick-Ass and
I'm like no if you're gonna be kicking
ass like look like you practiced a
little bit to kick ass and I told her
that they had her in that mode here like
yeah if in
in the hands of the folks who had made
the previous films I would have loved to
have seen that character because that's
another cool opportunity whistler's
daughter new addition to the team New
Generation it's a Trope but it's also
something that I think would work really
nicely Works decently here but yeah just
he could have been richer any world in
which we would see her again
I mean now with the Multiverse and all
that stuff I mean who knows because she
is the way I thought I doubt it but it
was possible the way I felt about her
and this is how I feel about Emily Blunt
and Edge of Tomorrow where it's just
like I feel like there's you're you're
really really good with the movements
yeah I believe everything every shot
every like you really like you said she
bulked up and she just looked
a killer oh yeah like I I not no slight
to her and I I liked her a lot in Texas
Chainsaw as well that remake but like
it's one of those casting choices at
this moment in time where you're like
okay this could easily be just sort of
like here's your catapults we're gonna
try and get you into movies now from TV
and not to say that I had like a low
expectation or any particular
expectation but yeah after you know the
movie finished I was like yeah she
really showed up to this and like she is
as much as I think Ryan Reynolds Shirley
probably gets the attention for this
movie in terms of Supporting Cast like I
thought she held it down with what she
was given I would be happy to see that
character again and that rapport with
blade again I was bummed about Natasha
Leone like because I thought yeah it's
she's got nice presents I like the
character they developed her and her
daughter it's just so brief you know
it's like I could have done with a
little bit you could have introduced
like this whole team in ways that
actually make us care about them so that
once everything happens later and it's
not just oh he's got a kid that's a bad
thing to do we gotta stop him you know
yeah definitely yeah this entire Trilogy
had a lot of Natasha Leone so like it
had so just I'm thinking back to the
second one with um our our dude from
Walking Dead yeah um you know just
Norman Reedus thank you
just people that you wouldn't expect
that or that I didn't even know like I
didn't know that Ryan Reynolds and
Jessica Biel were in this I didn't know
I didn't know anybody was in these
movies at all and every movie I feel
like you and I were like whoa that
person that person Triple H I'm gonna be
kicking myself about the next 10 years
okay forgive yourself that happens to
the best of us I can't it's all good I
know when that hotline bling that can
mean it could only mean one thing
more Drake preferences
oh that's a recycled one from earlier
um but yeah really good not not not
great not terrible okay solid is is fun
I had fun yeah I don't know if I would
even I don't know if I would even go so
far as to call it solid okay that's me I
I'm allowed to say so absolutely I'm
glad you thought it was solid I'm sorry
that you did it's a solid experience
it's weird it's not the word I would go
for because I think it is like kind of a
weird medley of moments and it's just
yeah it's it's just not as expert not as
graceful not as you're right it's not
consistent so solid you would think it'd
be like a consistent I think more like
to me the medium is the the average is
solid yeah like when you combine the
highs and lows and divide it's solid
sure yeah I can see that it's like I
feel like everything was there you know
they had everything they needed for
greatness
I think this they got me with
enjoyability at the very least you know
good yeah I'll take that is there
anything we miss is there anything else
you wanna you wanna touch upon try
everything you're feeling particularly
passionate about I don't know yeah this
is fun it's fine yeah Dominic Purcell
good to see you good to see you all this
is very much yeah this looks like a
bunch of people hopping in from from TV
this time I'm gonna miss Wesley I am too
like that's the thing is no matter what
in these movies like he is great and
he's a good core yep you know that's it
like this movie feels the most
impersonal in so many respects because I
feel like in some ways it doesn't even
fully you got Ryan Reynolds narrating it
doesn't even fully feel like we're a
hundred percent like I feel like the
first two you feel like you're with
Blade the entire way whereas here you're
kind of hopping around to a bunch of
stuff in a way that feels a little less
focused I don't know
but uh
solid uh Ron joxie it's Ron joxie solid
time at the B Movie
exploitation Cinema but what did you
guys think leave us your blade Trinity
thoughts do you love this movie do you
think it's underrated are we slagging
off your favorite Motion Picture let us
know oh no and uh what should we check
out next and uh oh those dogs were kind
of neat I like that they brought back
the reaper mouth for the dog I like a
good Palm a good yeah a vampom
well guys
pet your Vamps uh kiss your moms and hey
before we get out of here let's do a
paper
Mikhail
Lyndon McHale lives in Sweden a word
that's right that's right word and that
was the last image or you know before
the post-credits scene you know that was
the last sentiment the movie left us
with and if there's anybody who is good
with a word who is eloquent
it's Mikhail Lyndon he's a classy guy
and everybody from Sweden seems to be
classy Sweden's full class dude I I
believe that I've never met a Swedish
person that wasn't like very sweet sweet
and Sweet it's just a sweet sweet
totally yeah and the last name Linden
what do you know about Lyndon Johnson oh
not a lot you should enlighten me with
your historical prowess he's a president
yeah Lyndon Baines Johnson is that true
yeah Lyndon B should have been oh yeah
the L Beach secretly our favorite Linden
is you oh yeah no no no Lyndon Johnson
doesn't hold a candle to Mikhail Lyndon
it doesn't hold him a candle you
basically were saying you should be
president you should be president of
Sweden of Sweden and here yeah or the
Prime Minister whatever your government
that setup is and if you were a vampire
you know because you got a lot of you
know older historical you know know
history-rich buildings and architecture
and just you know you're from an older
part of the world so I imagine that you
know if anybody our patreon is likely to
have some vampire genes hiding down
somewhere in their uh in their genome it
could be you and uh very true and if
anybody was to turn us I would be
honored if it was Mikhail honestly you
know I would let you get get all close
and and bite my neck well Swedish Fish
are red and blood is red but Swedish
Fish are apparently not Swedish
according to Mikhail he sent us a
message
yes I gotta get back to him directly
this is a this is a good dad joke
um because we're talking about food
things where do you know that french
fries aren't made in France
they're made in Greece
[Music]
that's for you that's for you Mikhail we
love you stay crispy and uh we'll catch
you next month stay pledged and uh yeah
stay sweet
I don't think you can help it I mean you
know technology is advancing every day
you can change whatever you want pretty
soon you'll have designer babies why
can't you have designer tomorrow for
yourself solid anyway peace buddy